-Despite
the multitasking involved
with being the president,
Trump still finds a way
to enrich himself
and his family financially,
so, today we wanted to check in
on one particularly
insidious way
Trump and us his family have
been profiting, specifically,
from a policy
that was supposed to benefit
the low-income communities
Trump promised to help.
This is "The Check In."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding ding ]
When then-candidate Trump was
campaigning for the presidency,
back when the words
"President Trump" sounded like
one of those silly oxymorons,
like jumbo shrimp
or moderate Republican,
[ Laughter ]
he was promising to help
America's
impoverished communities
and he did it in the only way
Donald Trump knows how:
by insulting the very people
he was trying to convince
to vote for him.
-Look how much
African American communities
have suffered
under Democratic control.
To those, I say the following:
What do you have to lose?
Look, what do you have to lose?
You're living in poverty.
Your schools are no good.
You have no jobs.
58% of your youth is unemployed.
[ Laughter ]
What the hell
do you have to lose?
[ Laughter ]
-Jesus!
He tried to sell his policies
the same way drug dealers
try to sell meth.
[ Laughter ]
"Look, you're livin' in poverty.
You got no job,
why not let crystal
take the wheel for a while?
[ Laughter ]
Whaddya got to lose?"
Trump actually instituted
a policy which he claimed
was specifically meant
to build up
America's abandon cities
and towns.
Tucked away in the unpopular
GOP tax bill
was a specific tax benefit
referred to
as opportunity zones,
which sounds like
a weird sex manual
from the '70s, you know.
[ Laughter ]
"Things were dead in the bed
with Barb and I, but after I
found her opportunity zone,
it's a whole other story."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's tax bill contained
an incentive
that allows investors
to delay paying taxes
if they agree to invest money
into an area
that desperately needs it,
or, as it's known,
an opportunity zone.
In theory,
it sounds like a good idea.
Distressed communities need
better schools and housing,
and that requires money.
Investors are hesitant
to pour cash into areas
that may not turn a profit,
so the administration
is offering benefits
for them to take that risk.
But the problem
with opportunity zones is
that only one of those promises
has been fulfilled:
The one where wealthy people
made even more money.
Reports show that the...
And, of course, the wealthiest
Americans are benefiting.
The Trump presidency is like
an M. Night Shyamalan movie,
if all the twists
are super obvious.
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump would've titled
"The Sixth Sense"
"Bruce Willis Is Dead."
[ Laughter ]
And, of course, some
of those wealthy Americans
reaping the benefits
of this program include
Trump's own family.
-Jared Kushner is selling
his stake in a company
that benefited
from the tax breaks that he
personally pushed for.
-The Kushner family already owns
real estate on the Jersey shore,
but spent an extra $13 million
in Long Branch,
after the area was deemed
an opportunity zone.
Kushner has projects
in other opportunity zones,
including Jersey City
and Maryland,
that could get a boost in value,
all raising the question:
Who really profits?
-Jared Kushner?!
What a coincidence
that the president's son-in-law,
who works in the White House,
would benefit financially.
I guess he's
in an opportunity zone.
[ Laughter ]
So, Jared Kushner, the moray eel
who was kissed a princess
and turned halfway
into a prince,
[ Laughter and applause ]
is making a killing.
So, how? How, exactly,
are the wealthy, like Kushner,
benefiting from this plan?
Well, the vague language
of the law
leaves it up to investors
to decide what kind of projects
and developments
they wanna build.
There's nothing that forces them
to actually help
low-income communities.
On top of that,
the qualifications
for what defines
an opportunity zone
are extremely broad,
which defeats the very purpose
of this program.
-Clear pattern, so far,
is if you're an investor
and you're gonna invest
in a zone,
are you going to do it
in a developed city
that's already gentrified
or are you gonna do it
in a truly distressed part
of the country,
that is going to be a risk?
So, a lot of the money
is going to be
toward the sure investment,
which, in this case,
we're already seeing is
in the highly developed,
already expensive,
high-employment parts
of the country.
-Some opportunity zones
have also been criticized
for not being
economically distressed.
Almost 200 of the zones
qualified simply
by being next
to low-income areas.
-So the whole concept
of opportunity zones
sounds great, but it is
actually terrible.
It's basically R. Kelly.
Sounds great.
[ Laughter ]
Is actually terrible.
[ Applause ]
And this is reportedly --
[ Cheering and applause ]
This is reportedly becoming
the norm for this program.
According to The New York Times,
recent opportunity zone
projects include...
[ Laughter ]
A spa for pets
is not the kind of thing that
helps America's inner cities.
That is not what they
were crying out for.
"I'm having trouble
finding work and paying rent,
but the real issue is my cat
desperately needs a soft scrub."
[ Laughter ]
And, because the tax benefit
is lining the pockets
of the wealthy,
instead of helping
low-income areas,
a government agency
is now investigating the program
and Kushner's role in it.
-An internal watchdog group
with the Treasury Department
is taking a look into the way
the Trump administration
is rolling out
opportunity zones.
-The president's son-in-law,
Jared Kushner,
recently announced
he was soliciting investments
in these opportunity zones,
which prompted
the Treasury Department's
inspector general
to open an inquiry
into the program.
-You could do good things
with this money,
if that was your mission.
Or, you could just make high-end
stuff and get a tax break,
and that's what you're
seeing with Kushner
and I'm glad the IG
is gonna look into it.
Hopefully, Trump doesn't try
to squash that.
-I got a feeling that Trump
is gonna try and squash that.
[ Laughter ]
If there's one thing
Trump is good at,
it's squashing,
whether it's investigations,
testimony,
or himself into a golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
I --
"I don't think you're
gonna fit, sir."
[as Trump]
No, I can squash.
[ Laughter ]
So, despite Trump's promises,
opportunity zones ended up
benefiting the rich,
instead of helping the poor,
so, to answer Trump's
original question,
these communities have
everything to lose,
if he remains in office.
This has been "The Check In."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding ding ]